Forbes Magazine I have to say we looked
and this is uh I proposed this week with
all the financial news because they've
been sort of the the Bible I mean of the
magazines I've I've been known about
financial matters and five days before
the Silicon Valley Bank crashed there
look at their their head they had a
America's best banks list they made
America's Best Bank five days before and
this is not the only time I don't
remember if you remember weworks which
was valued at like I don't know 40
billion dollars or something and this
guy Adam Newman was the guy I was going
to take it was going to be the biggest
thing we works and that crashed
Elizabeth Holmes was also on the cover
of Forbes
was her company that is she is now going
to jail she was sentenced to 11 years in
jail Sam bankman freed was on the cover
of Forbes
I'm not kidding and he's looking at like
100 years in jail so we went back
through the files and I could tell you
some of these covers for Forbes over the
years would you like to see I mean they
have
the best at prognosticating I gotta say
uh look at this one we've seen the
future and it's spelled Sears yeah
another
[Applause]
restaurant Trends 2020 buffets buffets
buffets
that did not age well uh Prince Harry
and Megan the power couple that will
save the monarchy
the sky's the limit for Malaysia
Airlines
[Applause]
uh Investors Guide 1995 we're all in on
CD racks
all right
going places with Jeffrey Epstein all
aboard the military Express with Bill
Clinton Prince Andrew and Donald Trump
um Yeezy Street how Kanye West will help
Adidas Escape its German past
[Applause]
and of course Myspace move over Facebook
social media has a new boss
[Applause]